[Musik]
und in berlin bin ich verbunden mit
roderich kiesewetter von der cdu er ist
obmann im auswärtigen ausschuss und
gleichzeitig vorsitzender des
parlamentarischen kontrollgremiums wir
erreichen ihn im paul löbe haus mitten
im bundestags ist plenarwoche
kiesewetter beginnen wir bei der
bewertung des nahostkonflikts der
bewaffnete konflikt in gaza israel
treibt viele um auch in der deutschen
politik aber das reicht nicht was ist zu
tun
nun zunächst einmal sind die
internationalen vermittlungsbemühungen
zu stärken
aber zweitens muss auch sehr nüchtern
analysiert werden und darauf möchte ich
zuerst eingehen die hamas nutzt die
schwäche der palästinenserführung
dramatisch aus und hat sich sicherlich
in ihrem vorgehen verkalkuliert und
zugleich nutzt die hamas mit ihren
terror angriffen auch die schwäche der
regierungsbildung in israel aus vier
wahlen in zwei jahren auch die jetzige
regierungsbildung scheint nicht
erfolgreich zu sein netanyahu es nicht
damit beauftragt das bedeutet also alle
vermittlungsbemühungen müssen auch die
befindlichkeiten innerhalb israels und
innerhalb der palästinenser betrachten
bei den palästinensern kommt noch hinzu
dass wahlen verschoben wurden die im
januar versprochen wurden und im mai
stattfinden sollten
und dies sind alles punkte die natürlich
ein ungeheures eskalationspotenzial
haben so dass wir von dem klassischen
diplomatischen vermittlungsbemühungen
weiter und weiter entwickeln müssen es
reicht also nicht aus wieder drei punkte
pläne zu entwickeln sondern hier geht es
auch tatsächlich um tiefere
befindlichkeiten die diplomatische karte
wenn wir gleich noch ein bisschen
ausführlicher besprechen vorher
vielleicht noch mal eine einschätzung zu
dem was in der region selber militärisch
passiert ist auch sie haben das am
wochenende mit bekommen die israelis
haben einen von medien genutztes
hochhaus in gaza zerbombt man kann es
nicht anders sagen das hat herrn biden
in washington ziemlich verärgert und er
hat sofort eine thalia angerufen
ist das noch durch selbstverteidigung
gedeckt nun es sollen so sagen die
israelis unter dem sollten wir auch
vertrauen in diesem gebäude auch
geheimdienst büros der hamas seien und
es sollen dort auch entsprechend
terroristen gewesen sein nur das sind
grenzfälle und die können wir natürlich
aus berlin sehr leicht beurteilen und
einschätzen
aber die wirklichkeit vor ort ist nun
mal so dass in solchen konflikt flaggen
auch mit der wahrheit gespielt wird ich
tendiere dazu israel hier glauben zu
schenken zumal israel über eine stunde
vorher
diejenigen die das gebäude genutzt haben
auch gewarnt haben
aber es ist durchaus ein grenzfall
reporter ohne grenzen hat das ja zu
recht auch angesprochen
kiesewetter lassen sie uns die haben das
vorgeschlagen über diplomatie sprechen
im grunde genommen muss man ja sagen
über das schweigen der diplomaten so wie
wir es bisher erleben die eu die
europäische union hat ein paar tage
gebraucht für ein paar besorgte tweets
ist dass jetzt diese neue außenpolitik
der europäer nun unser außenminister
selbst hat ja deutlich gemacht dass wir
mindestens einen drei punkte plan
brauchen aber das nützt natürlich gar
nichts wenn deutschland hier vorprescht
wir brauchen hier eine europäisch
abgestimmte position deshalb ist es gut
dass ich morgen die eu außenminister
treffen und das ist auch wichtig dass
borel hier eine position erarbeitet
aber wir müssen auch ehrlich sein in den
vergangenen jahren hat sich die eu
vorrangig auf die seite der
palästinenser gestellt und wenig
verständnis für die israelischen
sicherheitsbedenken gehabt deswegen war
es so wichtig dass wir deutschen uns
uneingeschränkt auf die israelische
seite gestellt haben
aber die eu wird nicht umhin kommen denn
es gibt ja auch vorschläge aus russland
das nahost quartett zu beleben das sind
die europäische union die vereinten
nationen die usa und russland
und spätestens wenn das greift und ich
halte diesen vorschlag für gut dann muss
die europäische union mit klaren
positionierungen kommen und dazu gehört
auch dass druck auf die palästinenser
ausgeübt wird dass sie endlich die
wahlen durchführen sie haben eine seit
15 jahren erst seit 15 jahren
legitimierte politische führung das geht
nicht mehr das trägt die jugend nicht
mehr mit und auch nicht die
palästinensische bevölkerung also hier
liegt vieles im argen
die einschätzung würden wir sicher
teilen dass wenn die europäer schon
nicht richtig zu einem punkt kommen dass
dann andere gefordert sind zum beispiel
die vereinigten staaten mann hatte am
anfang den eindruck dass er beiden ein
bisschen auf dem falschen fuß erwischt
wurde und erst mal ein paar tage
gebraucht hat bisher ein emissär in die
region entsandt hat was erwarten sie
persönlich jetzt von washington auch
unter dem hintergrund eines quartett so
wie sie es angesprochen haben
also die usa kommen jetzt in der
realpolitik an beiden hat ja sehr stark
die regelbasierte internationale ordnung
in seinen ersten 100 tagen gestärkt mit
einer ganzen reihe von projekten
klimaschutz abkommen das abkommen mit
dem iran und vielem mehr
das ist gut aber jetzt kommen die
fraktionen des alltags und das haben wir
so nicht vorhergesehen obwohl natürlich
alle paar jahre immer wieder diese
eskalationen auf uns zukommen und was
eben fehlt ist ein plan was passiert
nach der gewalt und ich denke dass hier
hat er sehr gut engagiert sein wird auch
zu klären was passiert am tag iks wenn
der waffenstillstand da ist also wenn
der terrorangriff mit den raketen
aufgehört hat wenn die israelische
gewalt aufgehört hat wie kommt man an
den verhandlungstisch und dabei muss in
dem drei punkte plan von mars ein
vierter punkt ergänzt werden es geht
hier auch um wahlen möglichst unter
internationaler aufsicht in den
palästinensischen gebieten
wir brauchen eine legitime
palästinensische führung um überhaupt
sinnvoll verhandlungen zu führen das
muss inzwischen endlich auch im
interesse israels sein
des weiteren geht es darum den status
ost-jerusalems so zu definieren dass
keine seite das völkerrecht bricht auch
hier gab es ja ausgangspunkt für
eskalation vor gut einer woche
also ich erwarte dass wir deutscher satz
für eine starke position der eu werben
also mit unseren deutschen interessen
staatsraison israel und zweitens dass
wir die us vermittlungsbemühungen
stärken das glaube ich wird dann
aussicht auf erfolg haben herr
kiesewetter die letzte frage geht an den
vorsitzenden des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums dieser konfliktes mehr
oder weniger durch verschiedene
demonstrationen nicht nur nach europa
sondern auch nach deutschland ganz
speziell exportiert wurden anti
israelische demonstrationen
pro-palästinensische die aus dem ruder
gelaufen sind waren die
sicherheitsbehörden hier schlecht
vorbereitet der bund deutscher
kriminalbeamter sagt ja man hat nicht
genau hingeschaut was ich hier geht es
auch um unsere struktur des
verfassungsschutzes wir haben einen
bundesverfassungsschutz aber wir haben
eben auch 15 länder verfassungsschutz
einrichtungen und das halte ich
angesichts der sicherheitslage für
überholt wir müssen den
bundesverfassungsschutz stärken
und brauchen was den verfassungsschutz
angeht eine bessere koordinierung der
landesverfassungsschutz ämter aber auch
der landeskriminalämter mit dem
bundeskriminalamt
es kann nicht angehen dass bestimmte
gruppen in unserer bevölkerung auch wenn
sie erst kurz hier sind sich den
latenten rechtsradikalismus von altnazis
zunutze machen genauso umgekehrt dass
hier migranten instrumentalisiert werden
für gewalt gegen israel oder gewalt
gegen juden und jüdinnen in deutschland
hier bedarf es strikte anwendung unserer
gesetze und einer glaube ich schon
stringenteren koordinierung der
verfassungsschutz arbeit vielleicht muss
am ende ein einheitlicher
verfassungsschutz stehen der enger
koordiniert mit dem bundeskriminalamt
zusammenarbeitet ich glaube dass hier
die föderale ordnung sich mehr an einer
stärkung des bundes orientieren muss
herzlichen dank für diese klaren
aussagen das war roderich kiesewetter
von der cdu bundestagsfraktion ist ob
man im auswärtigen ausschuss und
vorsitzender des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums danke nach berlin